>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Diana Ingram: All right,
so we're going to get started.
Welcome everyone, I'm Diana Ingram
I'm the Executive Director here
at Hill Center at the
Old Naval Hospital.
And I just have to ask -- well
first of all, it's so lovely to see
such a mixture of ages in folks, but
is there anyone who has never been
in this building before
would you raise your hand.
Excellent, welcome.
>> That's great.
>> Diana Ingram: Come back.
Take a look at the program
highlights that are on your chair,
there's all kinds of
fabulous things happening.
But the neatest thing
that's happened aside
from this event tonight next
Wednesday, the beautiful artwork
that you see that was just put
up we're having our opening
reception with the artist.
So please come back 6
p.m. next Wednesday.
We have sparking water
and wine and mixed nuts
and it's a fun time for all.
Tonight take a moment to
turn off your mobile devices
if you would please.
And it is a great pleasure to
welcome you to the 11th edition
of life of a poet, it's amazing.
Featuring always effervescent
fabulous poets,
but tonight Dunya Mikhail, the
enigmatic, effervescent poet
in residence and Ron Charles,
of course, who is, you know,
such a fabulous raconteur.
If you've missed any
of the previous life
of a poets conversations they are
up on our YouTube channel and also
on the Library of Congress'
website I believe.
So it's a really fascinating
archive.
The series is made possible
through the generous support
of National Capital Bank.
So if you live on Capitol Hill
and don't bank there consider
banking there, we like them.
And the format.
Directly following the conversation
Dunya will sign books here.
Yes, it's a slightly new format
because some people didn't
get their books signed
and they didn't get
to buy them, so here.
Then everyone is invited
to adjourn to Bayou Bakery,
which is right, you
know, right there.
And there's a 15% discount,
which you may not even need
to use tonight, so save the
15% discount and come back
for another evening at Bayou Bakery.
Okay, please join me in welcoming
Robert Casper, head of the Library
of Congress' Poetry
and Literature Center.
He is also the program's director
for the Poetry Society of America.
Casper served as membership
director for the Council
of Literary Magazines and Presses
and I guess 11 years ago now
founded Jubilat, one-of-a-kind.
It publishes the best of
contemporary poetry anywhere.
So let me turn this over
to Rob Casper, thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Robert Casper: Thanks Diana,
thanks to all of you for coming
out on a suddenly cold
evening, oh it's okay.
Bayou Bakery the gumbo's
really good, it's worth going
to get it afterwards and they
actually have good coffee
drinks too.
We're thrilled to be back here.
Thanks to Miriam Brownlow
who dreamed this series
up a few years ago and
here we are at number 11.
Of course, we want to thank the
Washington Post for its support
and I think our Washington Post
book world editor, Ron Charles.
To think that once upon a time
Ron was only focusing on fiction
at our city's great paper.
What he's done over the course of
10 programs I believe will continue
to entertain and educate
poetry lovers
for the years and decades to come.
And it's worth checking out the
webcast of the videos on our website
and in the insider's YouTube
channel, they're just remarkable.
Before I talk about tonight's
featured poet let me say a little
bit about the Poetry and Literature
Center at the Library of Congress.
We are home to the poet
Laureate consultant in poetry,
our current poet laureate is Juan
Felipe Herrera, who is terrific
and fun and wild and sweet
and worth seeing when he comes
into town next week and in April.
We also host a range of
programs such as this one,
most of them are just down
the street at the Library.
If you want to find out more
about our programs you can visit
our website www.LOC.gov/poetry.
We've also left out some surveys
that should've been on your chairs.
We want to find out what you
think about this program,
get your comments so that
we can improve upon it,
though it's really sort
of impossible to improve
on what Ron Charles is
about to do and I mean
that completely sincerely.
>> Ron Charles: Let's not waste
too much time filling that out.
>> Robert Casper: I had a fun 10
minutes before the event basically
saying I love Ron Charles so
much I don't even know what
to do with myself.
So anyway, please give
us your feedback,
let us know what you
think that would be great.
And now I'm excited to
introduce Dunya Mikhail
to begin our 2016 season.
Mikhail was born in Iraq in
1965 and was forced to flee
in the wake of the first Gulf War.
She's the author of six books
in Arabic and one Italian.
Her three books in
English all published
by New Directions publishers
and I believe all three are
for sale outside include
The War Works Hard,
Shortlisted for the Griffin
Prize and named one of 25 books
to remember from 2005 by
the New York Public Library,
Diary of a Wave Outside the Sea,
which won the 2010
Arab-American book award
and most recently the Iraqi Nights.
Mikhail's honors also include the
UN human rights award for freedom
of writing and a Kresge
Artist Fellowship.
The cofounder of the
Mesopotamian form for art
and culture she's an
Arabic special lecturer
at Oakland University in Michigan.
And for her actually even today it's
somewhat warm coming from Michigan.
Mikhail is here to participate
in the Al-Mutanabbi Street
Starts Here DC 2016 Book Arts
and Culture Festival
led by Split This Rock.
For the last two months
exhibits, programs
and events have commemorated
the 2007 bombing
of Baghdad's historic
bookselling street.
A big thanks to Split This Rock
Executive Director Sarah Browning
who is here, Sarah.
[ Applause ]
Sarah is making this happen.
To find out more about the events
in the festival there are a number
of events coming up
in the weeks to come,
including events with
our future speaker.
You can check out this website
I'm just going to give it to you,
it's www.amsschdc2016.org or you
can go to Split This Rock website
and click on the link and you
should be able to check it out.
But I strongly encourage you do it.
For this series for life of a poet
tonight offers us an opportunity
to expand Ron's ongoing
engagement with poets
and poetry beyond our
country's borders.
This seems apt for our capital
city considering the debates among
thinkers of all types, positions
and perspectives within the district
on all things international.
I look forward to the next hour
and the ways it will surely show
me why Dunya Mikhail's poems need
to be part of that debate.
Please join me in welcoming
Ron Charles and Dunya Mikhail.
[ Applause ]
>> Ron Charles: It's such
a delight to have you here.
>> Dunya Mikhail: My pleasure.
>> Ron Charles: And to
have read your poems
and to have been so moved.
While preparing for this interview
I ran across an exasperated poem
in which you write, please don't
ask me America I don't remember
on which street or with
whom or under which star.
Don't ask me I don't remember.
I'm going to ask you though.
I'm going to ask you anyway.
You're our 11th poet, you're
our first foreign-born poet,
of course you're our
first Iraqi poet
and you're the first poet whose
life story is so death-defying.
No it is, I mean there is
some really exciting moments
in your biography and some of
course, some terrible moments.
Tell us why you had to leave Iraq.
>> Dunya Mikhail: Okay, well first
about you said first, first, first.
You know, I'm from Mesopotamia,
I mean originally Iraq.
And that place everything
that happened
in the civilian the culture
happened first in history.
But I left Iraq, I
had to leave Iraq --
well I was going to leave Iraq
earlier than I had to leave
when I graduated from
secondary school.
I was, you know, very good at math,
I mean I don't know how
serious was going to be,
but my father was serious
about it more than me.
And he thought I was genius in
math and I have to, you know,
to show the world that make
inventions in math and he wanted
to send me to America to,
you know, to study math more.
And that time was during
the Iraq Iran war
that when it was the
beginning of the war
when I graduated from
the high school.
And, you know, I was
so excited not about --
to be honest not about math,
but excited to go to America,
be independent and imagining
everything that I can do whatever.
Like read any book, even bad
books and a lot of things,
maybe be in a small apartment
versus our house was full of guests
like around-the-clock people
I don't know my mother was
so social she's not like, so always.
They were lovely, but I wanted
that something different and.
>> Ron Charles: You were 18, 19?
>> Dunya Mikhail: Eighteen I think.
What age we graduate from 15, 16,
well [inaudible], yeah 18 maybe.
>> Ron Charles: Yeah.
>> Dunya Mikhail: Yeah,
I'm 18 you're right.
So and anyways, so I was
talking about it 12 hours a day
and the other 12 hours
just imagining,
you know, what's going to happen.
But then when we went to the
passport office to get permission
because we had to get permission
to leave the country all came
to nothing because they said the
law doesn't allow women to travel
to study at their expenses
during the time of war.
So of course my father
saw my disappointment,
so he said you know what
this should be temporary
because the war will not last
forever and this law will change.
Why don't you study English
as you prepare for America,
so that's how I went to
the English literature?
And then in the College, University
of Baghdad and with literature
and friends to be honest I
forgot about America, about math
and about all that I
was busy and, you know,
very engaged with these things.
But it happened after
graduation and by the way,
I graduated from the University of
Baghdad and the law didn't change.
The war was still over and
the law didn't change but.
What happened is that in the 95
Diary of a Wave Outside the Sea
in Arabic part one came out and.
>> Ron Charles: This is your?
>> Dunya Mikhail: Yeah.
>> Ron Charles: Your first book?
>> Dunya Mikhail: In Iraq it was not
first, no before it was number --
this book was number
three, number three in Iraq.
So there were two books before.
But this when this came out
we have censorship department,
we have to have permission
before we publish,
it's an actual building
with actual employees.
So that their job title is
to watch, you know, what.
>> Ron Charles: To
protect the populous.
>> Dunya Mikhail: Yes, yes.
>> Ron Charles: From bad ideas.
>> Dunya Mikhail: And
yes to protect you
from bad ideas you're
right, that's perfect.
And then there was a passage that
was highlighted by the censor
that should be taken away.
And I said you know what it's
a very small text it doesn't --
I can't afford taking anything
away, it's a small one.
He said you know what,
so he wanted to be
on the safe side I don't blame him,
he said I will just put the
note and it's up to you.
But then I didn't take
anything away.
And then there was somebody came to
my office in the Baghdad Observer
and he pretended he's journalist
he wants to interview me,
but I know my colleagues the
journalists he was not journalist.
>> Ron Charles: But this time
you were a working journalist.
>> Dunya Mikhail: In the
Baghdad Observer yes.
And then he was really
investigating,
he was asking all these
questions that I were --
so I was suspicious about.
Because he was also focusing on this
passage that I didn't take away.
And I was like pretending he's
real journalist saying, you know,
it's not the task of the writer to
explain it's the task of the reader.
>> Ron Charles: So you
were both pretending.
>> Dunya Mikhail: Yes.
>> Ron Charles: Both
knew what was happening.
>> Dunya Mikhail: Yes.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Dunya Mikhail: And then I had
some links, friends who had links
in the, you know, that somebody told
me a friend, her son-in-law knew
that there's a report out
and she said, you know,
as soon as possible
leave the country
because the report [inaudible]
higher rank it's not good.
So but it was very complicated
the paperwork to leave
and I don't know should I continue
then what happened or maybe because,
you know, because how I left
the poetry really saved my life.
And when I say that really is
not metaphorical it's real,
that's how I left true poetry but.
>> Ron Charles: You had
to change your occupation
from journalist to poet.
>> Dunya Mikhail: Exactly.
>> Ron Charles: Then
you were free to go.
>> Dunya Mikhail: Yes, because well.
>> Ron Charles: Please leave.
>> Dunya Mikhail: Yes, as a
poet you don't need a leave
of absence from anywhere.
>> Ron Charles: Nobody cares.
>> Dunya Mikhail: Yeah, but
leave of absence in Iraq
that time was very complicated.
As a journalist you need to take
papers from the Union of Journalists
and that is very complicated,
you know, it takes forever
and so really poetry saved my life.
And it's written in my
passport I keep it, it's expired
but the profession is poet.
>> Ron Charles: And
Saddam saved you from math.
>> Dunya Mikhail: I
don't think of that.
I love math.
>> Ron Charles: You still love math?
>> Dunya Mikhail: I still love
-- no I stopped it I mean,
but I have that like you know how
you have first love you think of it,
you think about it sometimes.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Dunya Mikhail: Like
that like you forgot
about it, but it's first love.
>> Ron Charles: I was a
math major in college,
but now I look back I can't even --
I don't even know what the questions
are, I can't read it at all.
You received a message that let you
know it was time to get out fast
and that message was the
flowers are withering.
Weirdly poetic and tragic.
>> Dunya Mikhail: Yes,
this message was
from my friend fiction
writer I don't know
if I'm allowed [inaudible].
We agreed that okay,
because I left but I had
in mind maybe I come
back if things calm down.
So this was our code that if she
tells me the flower, you know,
are blooming and this
means okay, come back.
>> Robert Casper: Yes.
>> Dunya Mikhail: So
that was our code.
>> Ron Charles: The
flowers are blooming.
>> Dunya Mikhail: Because she can't.
>> Ron Charles: Right.
>> Dunya Mikhail: Talk
directly in the letter,
so that was her message
that don't come back.
She didn't want me back.
>> Ron Charles: This is a weird
question and none of us is in favor
of censorship of course,
but is there a way
in which censorship puts
pressure on language
that makes it more metaphorical,
more allegorical, more creative?
>> Dunya Mikhail: Yes, I mean that
exactly what was happening with me
and with other writers in Iraq
that we were using this
metaphors sometimes as shields.
I wanted to be understood,
I'm the kind of person I
like to be understood actually
by readers and by everybody,
but I didn't want to be
understood by the censors.
So that's using those metaphors
because the true readers they
understand you those metaphors,
but he censors maybe not.
Well a funny thing happened with
that metaphor I tell you maybe
if the time allows
it with the minister
of information and
culture with this.
But another funny thing a friend
from back home while I'm in here
in America, you know, I kept on
contact and he said to me Dunya,
you were writing better before.
So because he loved those metaphors
I was using they were maybe good
for my poetry.
>> Ron Charles: Right,
that's what I was wondering.
>> Dunya Mikhail: Yes.
>> Ron Charles: [Inaudible]
want that but in a way.
>> Dunya Mikhail: Yeah, it
looks like it served our poetry.
But a lot of you know
surrealists things happened.
>> Ron Charles: Right, I want to
look at one of those passages.
You note -- let's see here in this
diary about a shell, a seashell.
I wonder if you'd read this is
a very long work without breaks
and I'm just asking
her to read a section
of it here from there to there.
It's when you talk
about poetry as a shell.
>> Dunya Mikhail: This is
a [inaudible] by the way,
but it's okay that it's compliment
everybody says it's poetry yeah.
On the seashore was
an enormous shell
that contained the
protoplasm of poetry.
Someone brought it to me and
linked the essence of my life
with its invisible threads.
I felt like a kite looking
at the world from above.
Like any child little things
make me rise or fall that shell
of poetry drew me from or into
everything and let me do nothing
but play with it and glorify it.
I have tried many times to rid
myself of its magnetic power
and is deadly effect on me.
>> Ron Charles: That's
lovely and troubling.
What about poetry is like a shell
and why would you want
to get rid of it?
>> Dunya Mikhail: It's
annoying, it's --
well, you know, really
it's so obsessed.
Even one time I said to someone,
you know, so how you are,
I mean when you are a
poet not even I mean
as a writer it's easier
to say I'm a writer.
When you say I am a poet you
hesitate I don't know why.
And like people how you deal
with it first with yourself
like 24 hours a day you are obsessed
with something what is this
thing I am obsessed with this,
why am I obsessed with
tis all the time
and why is this directing my life,
everything is dictated by poetry.
And on the other hand like I
found myself one time saying
to someone yes, I write poetry,
but all my other habits are good.
Like then I thought about it I said,
so it's like as if
you defend yourself.
And as a matter of fact,
I even remember how
when I was teenager I
mean I was in my room
and I was lucky I had
the room of my own,
I mean Virginia Woolf was right
I mean it was very important.
And my mother we always
had a lot of guests
and I heard her one time saying
to the guest she is busy
writing her feelings.
And, you know, how embarrassing
that is to a teenager.
But you know why she
said that she said
because in Arabic the word [foreign
language] feeling is similar
to share poetry and Arabic is not
her first language [inaudible] is
her first, Arabic is her second.
And she made her own plural
of the two words to say --
she said it's like she's
busy writing feelings.
But you know now I
think of it I appreciate
that she considered writing feelings
important enough to excuse you
from coming and be with the guests
or from social daily, you know.
>> Ron Charles: Right.
>> Dunya Mikhail: And
things like that.
>> Ron Charles: That's lovely.
You were once asked if you
thought poetry was therapeutic
and you said poetry is
not medicine it's x-ray,
what do you mean by that.
>> Dunya Mikhail: Yes, I still
believe it's not healing,
it's not -- it's an x-ray that helps
you see the wound and understand it.
And it's like or if I say
something similar it's like a key
where you can open a door behind
which later you can see all
the wound that happened then.
I mean it's not, I mean
although it is not healing
and it's actually used less,
but it's very effective
at the same time it's strange.
So I'm trying to like it's really --
it's very effective like
and delicate like the trace
of the butterfly on the things.
But to say it can stand in front
and face of catastrophe I'm not sure
if it can do that, but we do resort
to poetry and we feel together --
we feel alone and we feel
together at the same time
when we see all this violence
that's happening in the world.
Not that it's going to, you know,
to heal I still believe it's
not the function of poetry.
But as if there's a possibility
of survival, but it's not final,
it's not final to say I survived
it doesn't mean you are saved,
it doesn't mean.
>> Ron Charles: Right, right.
In Diary of a Wave Outside the Sea
this remarkable autobiographical
book, I think it's a poem.
It about 120 pages, it's in
two parts, one written in Iraq
and one written in
America, it's sprawling
and it has this elastic form, it's
got dreams and narratives and myths
and reporting and epigraphs and
lyrics, it's just really strange.
I mean I haven't read anything else
like it except maybe
Leaves of a Grass.
What was your model for
this, what were you doing?
You say that you didn't
even think of it as a poem
which just strikes me as remarkable.
I mean clearly it is
a poem it's written
in highly metaphoric language,
it's broken into beautiful lines,
it uses repetition, it uses
all the elements of poetry.
Why would you think it's not a poem?
>> Dunya Mikhail: You know,
it had the symptoms of poetry,
such as the symptoms are similar
to like symptoms of falling in live
like you feel this
excitement and you are.
But it's happened I wrote
this after the second,
is it second war Gulf War we call
it or it's called many names.
It's called the 91 war, here
it was called Desert Storm
and in Iraq they called it
the mother of all battles.
It had nicknames, you know, so it
is and that war was very intense
and I very clearly
remember it very well.
I mean because simply we had a room
in the house called the
war room, the room of war.
>> Ron Charles: Was it
a safety room for you?
>> Dunya Mikhail: My mother prepared
that room she called it the war room
and we were not allowed to leave
the room during that war of 91.
And she designed it in a special
way like she taped the windows
so that the windows break
we don't get hurt so badly
and she taped the whole of the door
so that the chemical
weapons don't go through.
>> Ron Charles: That's intense.
>> Dunya Mikhail: And we were
suffocating because we were trying
to -- my brothers and I we were
taking turns to lit that candle
and it was not because
no oxygen there.
And even going to bathroom was a
problem because she was afraid --
she wanted us to die
or live altogether.
So she was not wanting
anybody going even
like to bathroom was
like quick, quick.
So anyways, it was something.
But what was I saying anyway?
>> Ron Charles: The
form of this book.
>> Dunya Mikhail: Okay, so that's
when I mean I had such an experience
in that war and right after I
didn't write it during the war,
but when it stopped I stated writing
this as I wanted some response
to the war it caused so much mess.
>> Ron Charles: Is it like
something you had read?
>> Dunya Mikhail: It was
so much mess that I felt
if I give it a form this mess in my
head, I wanted to give it some form.
And the title of it
actually I hate the saying
that they say you hit
a bird with two tones,
I hate to hit the birds [inaudible].
But I had two goals in the title.
One is as it is understood
like the wave outside the sea,
the sea is the society,
the environment
that you want to be out of.
But the second meaning sea in Arabic
[foreign language] also has another
meaning which means the
pattern, the metric pattern
because we have classic Arabic
poetry, it's traditional poetry.
It has 16 patterns and each one
is called [foreign language] sea
and mine was modern so I wanted
outside these patterns also.
So it had some.
>> Ron Charles: What we
would call free verse does
that relate in any way?
>> Dunya Mikhail: No, free verse
after the traditional [inaudible]
we call it there's a free verse
movement started in Iraq actually
in the 1940's by Iraqi poets
to Iraqi poets female
and male [inaudible]
and Badr Shakir al Sayyab they
started the free verse movement
and separate to other countries.
But that also had some
rules, it still has rhymes,
but it was more free with the
lines because the tradition was so,
so strict with the [inaudible] what
you called in this middle and all
that and it was just 16
founded by [inaudible] century.
And my friends other modern writers,
poets and I who were serious
about not only poetry,
but modern poetry.
Why should we all follow
a man's rules, you know,
but that was not welcome this
type of modern writing was not
so welcome in the media yet.
Anyways, so that was kind
of a response to the sea is
that it's outside what is familiar.
>> Ron Charles: Right.
>> Dunya Mikhail: A written style
of writing and also outside the sea,
the society, the environment
and that.
>> Ron Charles: Would you
read a passage here it's
about the bombing it starts
here and it runs onto here.
>> Dunya Mikhail: Okay.
The radio says that light planes
are dropping cluster bombs
on shelters and bridges.
I never heard of such a phrase
except as a cluster of grapes.
Oh life a suspension
bridge between two wars.
Why don't the flowers of
others like to bloom save
in the remains of our ashes.
The letters do not arrive,
the telephone does not
ring, nothing rings but me.
What time is it now, is the
war over, will they return,
was there enough room
in the sky for the birds
when the planes raised our dreams,
I'm sorry when the
planes raided our dreams
and turned everything to flour.
It was a night of extremes some
of the residents could not
sleep while others left forever.
And when the spots of slide
multiplied in the darkness,
flying things lost their minds.
No one could tell if the
birds had changed into planes
or if the planes had
changed into flaming birds.
Everything was shaking, the city
and the people inside the city,
the hearts inside the people and
the people inside the hearts.
The planes circled over the
capital, bumping its residence
into the villages towards an unknown
fate and toward the questions
of children that grown-ups
do not know the answers to.
The planes flew over at the
[inaudible] filling the eyes
of [inaudible] with dismay
as his horses left the city.
The planes flew over the shelters,
over the debris that collected
in the shelters, over the children
who slept under the debris,
over the body parts
that had been children,
over the ash the body parts became
over the walls sprinkled with ash,
over the drops of blood
on the walls.
In war no one is rescued from death.
The [inaudible] die physically
and the killers die morally.
>> Ron Charles: So beautiful and
so horrific, such a weird tension
between what's being
described in the language
and the rhythms of those phrases.
What's it like for you
to hear this in English
when you wrote in a
different language?
>> Dunya Mikhail: Yes, it's kind
of different when I did in Arabic,
you know, of course I did it
better excuse my bad reading.
>> Ron Charles: No, no.
>> Dunya Mikhail: My third language.
>> Ron Charles: You read lovely.
>> Dunya Mikhail: Yeah, it's
really my third language,
but I'm improving in it.
And, you know, English helped me
make more sensitive towards my
original language.
I kind of made me really think more
carefully about Arabic because,
you know, how your first
language is automatic.
But then because of
translation you go back and forth
and you even improve your first
language as a result of the second.
>> Ron Charles: War poetry has
such a long history like from Homer
and beyond I suppose all the
way up to our great Iraq poets,
our great Iraq war poets in America
like thinking of Brian Turner
and Kevin Powers, both
that you know from Iraq.
But your position to the war is
different you were never a soldier
is your primary difference,
as well as other differences.
You write on the first
morning of the new year all
of us will look up at the same sun.
You're not writing about being
in battle, which gives the poems
in your descriptions of
war such a different tenor.
I'd wonder if you'd read this poem
called Iraqis and Other Monsters.
>> Dunya Mikhail: Yeah
and this is really
about stereotyping the Iraqis, but
I found here in America you know
that Americans also are
stereotyped by our people.
Yeah, so this is we
have these ethic groups
and all the conflicts between.
Anyways, let me [inaudible].
Iraqis and Other Monsters.
They are terrifying, their heads are
dark and tremulous, no tremeliou --
how do you say it tremelious
[phonetic]?
>> Ron Charles: Tremulous.
>> Dunya Mikhail: Tremulous right.
They are terrifying, their
heads are dark and tremulous.
They roam the desert in
the form of bulls and lions
with swords gleaming in their eyes.
They rub their mustaches
when they make promises
or threats or when they flirt.
Smoke pours out of their massive
noses and rises to the sky.
They shake the earth with such
strength it wakes the dead.
They live in darkness
without water or electricity.
Dust is their food,
clay their bread,
they no neither sleep nor rest.
The war visits them every day
with new baskets of bones.
They have strange customs, the
Sunnis say the Shias all have tails,
the Shias carry keys to have
in their pockets in
case of sudden death.
The Kurds take to the
mountains when they fight
and when they dance the [inaudible].
The Chaldeans consult the
stars in all decisions.
The Syrians put feathers
on their heads
to prove they have
vanquished the eagle.
The Armenians throw themselves in
the river whenever they are annoyed.
The [inaudible] celebrate
their festivals
by staying home for three full days.
The [inaudible] honor the
peacock and consecrate letters.
The Turkmens are always waiting
for the Sultan to return.
When the sun sets and the
guns fall silent these Iraqis
and other monsters take out
their [inaudible] and make music
for the missing together
until morning.
And I want to say something
though about --
this was written before
all this happening,
well this is a pre-ISIS
era you know.
And I mean to be honest this would
be written different maybe I don't
know after because I am so
occupied, my mind is so occupied
with what's happening in
Iraq, especially in the north,
especially to the [inaudible]
minority and also
to Christians these days
that I'm afraid I have some
in [inaudible] now because of this.
Because I've been involved
with it day and night
and I've been writing my
new work on this thing.
>> Ron Charles: But this poem
does it stand outside all these
prejudices, all these stereotypes
it makes them all seem a little
ridiculous right?
Makes us realize that we can
transcend these ridiculous images
of one another for peace if
we would just be a little more
morally imaginative.
>> Dunya Mikhail: Yes, but at the
end they are all missing something
and that, I mean they are monsters
but in the poem they look monsters,
but they're really from inside
it's fragility and I don't know.
>> Ron Charles: Another one
of your poems captures the
city just before it ends.
It's a really startling,
frightening poem.
>> Dunya Mikhail: I
wonder which one.
>> Ron Charles: It's
called Five Minutes.
>> Dunya Mikhail: Oh, oh that
one, that's a very old one yes.
>> Ron Charles: What
like 2,000 years old?
>> Dunya Mikhail: Twentieth century.
I am a poet, when they say poet
from the 20th century I say whoa,
whoa I'm a dinosaur or
something still living.
>> Ron Charles: Yeah, yeah.
>> Dunya Mikhail: Yes and this was
imagining the last five minutes
in the world like last five minutes.
In five minutes the world will end,
the owner of the shop next-door
has just put up the closed sign
and gone away as if he knows
there's no time left for work.
There are other stores open, their
owners are still absorbed in work,
but the world will end in a group of
lively boys, rushes by the street,
following them a dog
leading an old man.
The traffic light is red,
the bus driver makes a slight
adjustment to the rearview mirror.
There are still several [inaudible]
that move across the mirror.
The driver pulls away now,
the traffic light is green.
It will keep changing
even after five minutes.
A young man checks his watch
and waits for the next bus.
In the public park a couple
walks past the statues
and smiles under the sun.
The statutes are carefree,
they stare firmly at nothing.
A tourist wanders full of
curiosity and takes pictures
of what will soon be absent.
There in the white hospital women,
their new babies too late the babies
might leave the world without names.
In one of the words they
will be left forever
in test tubes while the wiggling lab
mouse performing a test will be free
at last from the big
eye that always watches.
The test is not difficult, but time
will run out before the answer.
And it no longer matters
whether or not you knew,
smell the roses and keep going.
The rose always knows that the
world will end in five minutes.
The blue shirt in the shop window
seems beautiful on the mannequin.
A young woman points
it out to her friend
and they had toward the
revolving door to be swallowed
by the towering building.
On the wall glossy advertisements
huge sale, new remedy for wrinkles,
cigarettes don't harm your
health, but the world will end.
In his world room inside
the wall palace,
inside the wall city the
tyrant is chewing on an apple
and watching himself on television.
Who would believe that in five
minutes he will relinquish
his throne?
Another defendant receives
a life sentence,
his attorney wants an
appeal but the world will.
Passengers push through
the exit door,
others come in through
the entrance door.
A woman sets down her suitcase
and waves her hand it's not me.
A man waves to her from behind
the airport glass it's not you.
I don't know if they met or at the
time that university student prefers
to travel by train, it doesn't
make much difference now.
He has agreed with a
friend to go on a picnic,
I don't know if the picnic
ended before the world
or the world before the picnic.
As for me I'm writing a letter,
I don't think it will be
finished within five minutes.
>> Ron Charles: It's so haunting the
way you identify all these ordinary
little tales of people's lives
and hovering over that is the fact
that everything will be destroyed.
It really captures
the tragedy of war.
We sort of wince as we read
that poem knowing what's coming,
you know, having lived through it.
>> Dunya Mikhail: But this was
published in Iraq and, you know,
like what I meant by censorship
like that stands of tyrant and all
that they question you about
like what do you mean by that.
And it's happened one time a friend
published that's why they said your
poetry is subversive
they called it there.
And I had a friend, a very
nice friend who was also poet
and he was editor in one
of the Iraqi newspaper I don't
remember which one we had three.
And that poem pronoun which is in
the end of the world works hard
in 91 he published it
and he told me something.
He said you know what I
[inaudible] if someone asks you
who is the general in the
poem say that's Schwarzkopf.
So this was our ways of survival
like in Iraq, these ways, tricks.
>> Ron Charles: Nice, very nice.
>> Dunya Mikhail: So if they say
who's the tyrant I say like someone.
>> Ron Charles: It's good that
tyrants aren't very smart.
A very brief poem called The Plane.
The Plane arriving
from Baghdad carries,
it rises above the moon
reflected on the Tigris.
Above clouds piled like
corpses and an ancient harp
and the beating breasts and
the ones who were kidnapped.
It rises above the destruction
that grows with the children
and the long lines of the passport
office and Pandora's open box.
The plane and its exhausted
passengers will land 6,000 miles
away from an amputated
finger lying in the sand.
>> Dunya Mikhail: I love
when you read it's so good.
>> Ron Charles: No, I
should make you read it.
>> Dunya Mikhail: Oh my God.
>> Ron Charles: Just such --
it's such a devastating poem the
way it takes this world, you know,
world shaping action, the war, the
planes, all this political disaster
and then it brings us right
down, right down onto the ground
to one little moment that
says everything right,
which is that somebody died.
Somebody precious is
now blown to bits.
And of course it's startling too
and it's an amputated finger lying
in the sand, but even though it is.
But's a devastating little poem
that captures the whole war.
Bravo.
There's another one I want you
to read called The
Prisoner remember that?
[Inaudible] you haven't read
these as recently as I have.
Again, it's one of
these little moments.
As we experience the war, you
know, in the newspaper or on TV
and it just seem so abstract and so
large and so loud and so, you kind,
kind of videogamesque
[phonetic] for Americans.
And then you bring
us moments like this.
>> Dunya Mikhail: I thought
you going to read it, but so.
The President.
She doesn't understand
what it means to be guilty.
She waits at the prison entrance
until she seems him to say take care
of yourself as she always used
to remind him when he went off
to school, when he left for work,
when he returned while on vacation.
She doesn't understand what they are
saying now at the back of the podium
in their official uniforms.
The report that he
should be kept there
with [inaudible] strangers
it never occurred to her
as she sang lullabies on his bed
in those distant days someday he
would end up in this cold place
without windows or moons.
She doesn't understand,
the prisoner's mother doesn't
understand why she should leave him
just the visit is over.
>> Ron Charles: That's what war is
for actual people is
losing their family members,
being separated, being
bewildered by it.
I suppose all these are
based on actual friends
or experiences you've
heard about or knew about?
>> Dunya Mikhail: Yes,
we always heard of --
always somebody disappeared, I mean
when I was a journalist in Iraq.
I mean there was in the
corner of every newspaper
in Iraq there is a
saying, the same saying,
it says write feely whether
the government likes it or not.
But nobody believed
it we knew that was
like not even a joke it
was a trap and we were
because we were seeing
our colleagues disappear,
every day somebody disappearing
whether in prison or gone or like
in best case scenario
too what they call exile.
>> Ron Charles: Like you.
>> Dunya Mikhail: I
don't know what exile is.
>> Ron Charles: You.
>> Dunya Mikhail: Yes.
>> Ron Charles: Yeah,
that does seem.
>> Dunya Mikhail: That's
the best case.
>> Ron Charles: Preferable yes.
In the diary.
>> Dunya Mikhail: You know, I
wanted to say how lucky I was
that I had a suitcase, but
these days because, you know,
I can't get rid of these
images of those going on.
Now the people are
leaving with no suitcases,
with nothing just leaving.
>> Ron Charles: The story in
today's paper was so disturbing.
Just a little moment from the diary.
>> Dunya Mikhail: I wander
among the ruins like a word
in the dictionary roaming
in search of its meanings
in a language without verbs.
I'm a verb of the past trying vainly
to change to the present tense.
They said behind every window no
matter how small a horizon can
be seen.
Ever since I heard that I
have been drawing windows
that open up, do nothing.
This was all written like a long
time ago I don't even remember it.
Really seriously I'm so surprised.
>> Ron Charles: Still
incredibly powerful.
>> Dunya Mikhail: Thank
you for bringing of this.
>> Ron Charles: To wander among the
ruins like a word in a dictionary.
We're going to take a little break.
There is a weird sardonic humor
about the war in some of your poems
that I think comes from
having survived them.
A kind of cosmic absurdity.
One called Silent Movie.
>> Dunya Mikhail: Oh.
What I was, what was I thinking.
There in the sky's playground the
gods toss us around like purses
and cast us down from above
without speaking a word.
They watch us, but don't hear us.
We are a silent movie with a bad
director now wonder the gods get
bored or switch us off and go to
sleep or forget about us as we bend
like a question mark on an empty
screen or sneeze as we pray
for return of the gods
even without any words.
You know, I would change a
lot in this if I rewrite it.
It's interesting that you ask me
the poems I never read in public.
>> Ron Charles: This reminds me of
Gloucester and King Lear talking
about the gods killing
us for their sport.
I'm sure half the people
can recite the lines.
Then there's another one here with
a title called The War Works Hard.
It begins how magnificent the war
is, how eager and efficient early
in the morning it wakes up the
sirens and dispatched ambulances
to various places, swings corpses
through the air, it rolls stretchers
to the wounded, summons rain
from the eyes of mothers and digs
into the earth, dislodges
many things.
Summer life wasn't glistening,
others are pale and still throbbing.
It produces the most questions
in the minds of children.
The poem goes on like this with
this really strange kind of humor.
What are you reaching for there,
how magnificent the war is?
>> Dunya Mikhail: I
don't know it's how --
why I mean it's, I
know it's person fight.
I wanted to be treated
like something
like somebody like doing their job.
And it was, you know, in my mind
I think I'm not sure this comes
to my mind always as if like
what I saw the scenes from war
as if they are scenes
from thousands of films
that don't relate each other and
they're seen from here and there
and they come -- it's strange how
they come to your mind together.
But they are very vivid in
my mind that it's strange
because my memory is not
so good, I forget a lot,
I find myself it's
embarrassing how much I forget.
But how vivid are these scenes
in my mind from that time.
And so I get always question is this
about a certain war and it's not
about a certain war
it's about war itself.
>> Ron Charles: It's
always working hard.
>> Dunya Mikhail: Yes.
>> Ron Charles: Yes, too hard yeah.
It ends with these lines.
The war works with
unparalleled diligence,
yet no one gives it
a word of praise.
Let's talk about the immigrants, the
immigrant story which is your story.
>> Dunya Mikhail: Yes.
>> Ron Charles: You write as I left
I knew I was forgetting something,
it bothered me to leave it
behind, but I was determined not
to look back like Orpheus
leaving the underworld.
But of course you do
look back all the time.
>> Dunya Mikhail: Yes,
I mean this method
of Orpheus fascinated me always how,
you know, in case it's [inaudible]
but just in brief I tell
you sorry if you know it
and I'm repeating it to you.
But Orpheus lost his beloved wife
Eurydice and then he was promised
that he would have her back with one
condition if he doesn't look back
when she's after him from
underworld to the upper world.
But he does look back and
he loses her by that look.
But I always think,
I mean I even have
in the Iraqi [inaudible] poem
called The Gaze of Orpheus
because I wanted always like I want
to get rid of it, I talked about it,
about the gaze of Orpheus.
What if he didn't look back, but
you know kind of I understand him.
>> Ron Charles: Of course.
>> Dunya Mikhail: To look back,
I mean how can you
not look back I mean.
>> Ron Charles: But she
pays the price not him,
I mean he gets to leave.
>> Dunya Mikhail: Right, but
I think that looking back
because maybe he liked her so much
that he was making
sure she's behind him.
>> Ron Charles: Right definitely.
>> Dunya Mikhail: Or I mean the same
way like you can't not look back
to let's say your country,
your original country.
I know I mean that I said like
when you leave you have --
I mean a child me something
one time, a neighbor child.
She said you know why we have our
eyes in front of us because we want
to look forward not backward.
I said wow, I love that.
>> Ron Charles: Yeah, that's good.
You write why am I blamed
for departing from mirrors
that reflected what
I didn't like to see.
You remember that phrase, why am I
blamed for departing from mirrors
that are reflected what
I didn't like see it.
Who do you think, do you feel
a sense of blame for leaving,
even abandoning your country is that
sort of a nagging sense of guilt?
>> Dunya Mikhail: Yes, I mean on an
official and less official level,
on official level there
was a list where I was --
the list as being traitor because I
left without leave of absence I just
like escaped and everything,
suddenly [inaudible].
>> Ron Charles: You're
officially guilty.
>> Dunya Mikhail: Officially,
but also not even casually
what you call it or inside me,
I mean I don't know to leave
suddenly without saying goodbye
to anybody, your friends and.
>> Ron Charles: It sounds horrible.
>> Dunya Mikhail: And
even pictures and ID cards
and those were left and [inaudible].
But you know a neighbor of
us was so sincere he went
and he kept some of
these ID cards and.
>> Ron Charles: Nice [inaudible].
>> Dunya Mikhail: Some
pictures that was nice of him.
>> Ron Charles: You
got it eventually?
>> Dunya Mikhail: Not
everything, but he kept --
he told us when people were there
to like buy things or get things
and all he worried about is
the ID cards he took them
and kept them for later.
>> Ron Charles: This is a very
painful section of the diary,
which you apologize and apologize.
>> Dunya Mikhail: Also that's
an answer for your question.
I am sorry I left you
among the ruins.
I'm sorry I left without
saying goodbye.
I apologize to my new home for
carrying the ruins with me.
I apologize for not being able
to be in two places at once.
I apologize to the war for
avoiding its nightmares
by turning my face to the wall.
I apologize to the sirens for
preferring the sound of music
and the rhythm of water fountains.
I apologize for running
to lose weight instead
of running to escape explosions.
I have left my friends too
busy for their sufferings.
Life continues behind their backs.
I'm sorry away from you I look at
the blue spaces between skyscrapers
and the America of lottery
tickets, credit cards and fast food.
Leave you and love you.
>> Ron Charles: You
write in another poem.
We crossed borders lightly like
clouds, nothing carries us.
But as we move on we
carry rain and an accent
and a memory of another place.
The pain of leaving
people behind just seems
to me incalculable I can't
imagine what it's like.
As you say you had to leave very
quickly there were no going away
parties, no winding down,
no cleaning out your desk.
>> Dunya Mikhail: Not only that even
my brother had his wedding coming
in two weeks after that and I wanted
to wait two weeks and he said no,
you know, just go if you can because
we can send you the video later.
[ Laughter ]
>> Ron Charles: In one of your
poems you write there is a knock
at the door how disappointing
it is the New Year and not you.
Let's talk about that leaving
in a hurry this is
called I Was in a Hurry.
>> Dunya Mikhail: You know this
is the first poem I wrote here
in America.
>> Ron Charles: Oh my gosh.
>> Dunya Mikhail: After
not right away,
in the beginning I
didn't write I was trying
to find a space called
a place or something.
But when I returned to writing
like this was my returning
to writing poetry.
This was this first
poem I wrote here
and I really could connect more
better to the new place I felt more
when I was able to write.
>> Ron Charles: That helped.
>> Dunya Mikhail: It
felt more at home.
>> Ron Charles: It was therapeutic.
>> Dunya Mikhail: No.
[ Laughter ]
Almost got me.
>> Ron Charles: Yeah.
>> Dunya Mikhail: I Was in a Hurry.
Yesterday lost a country.
I was in a hurry and didn't
notice when it fell from me
like a broken branch
from a forgetful tree.
Please if anyone passes by
and stumbles across it perhaps
in a suitcase open to the sky or
engraved on Iraq like a gaping wound
or wrapped in the blankets
of immigrants or canceled
like a losing lottery ticket or
helplessly forgotten in purgatory
or rushing forward without a goal
like the questions of children
or rising from the smoke of war,
eroding in a helmet on the sand
or stolen in Alibaba's jar
or disguised in the uniform
of a policeman who stirred
up the prisoners and fled.
Or squatting in the mind of a
woman who tries to smile or scatter
like the dreams of new immigrants.
If anyone stumbles across
it return it to me please.
Please return it to me it's
my country I was in a hurry
when I lost it yesterday.
>> Ron Charles: I love the
way that poem rolls and seems
to pick up momentum as it goes.
Did you write it in English?
The poem, did you write
that poem in English?
>> Dunya Mikhail: Now.
>> Ron Charles: And someone
else translated it for you or?
>> Dunya Mikhail: You
mean did I write?
>> Ron Charles: Originally you.
>> Dunya Mikhail: Oh I wrote it
in Arabic I always
write in Arabic first.
>> Ron Charles: You
always -- even now.
>> Dunya Mikhail: Oh yeah I
always write in Arabic first.
You know, now I have the habit of
going on the page first from right
to left and left to right
like this and this, you know,
why it drives me crazy
that's one of the reasons.
>> Ron Charles: Much more efficient.
You could write in English clearly.
>> Dunya Mikhail: I think so.
>> Ron Charles: How
much time do we have?
>> Dunya Mikhail: Some sentences
sometimes in English first due
to their cultural connotations
being here sometimes.
>> Ron Charles: Your attitude
about America is complex.
>> Dunya Mikhail: My attitude.
>> Ron Charles: Your write
America is but a baby of a country,
she doesn't really cause problems,
she always thinks it's easier
to replace problems
than to fix them.
Your washer is broken
the repairman says,
it's easier to replace
it than fix it.
Your country is broken
the politician says,
it's easier to replace
it than fix it.
It's funny, but it's awful.
Other times your attitude
is even more playful
in a poem called Choices
you begin paper or plastic,
I am not sure how to respond.
I wish I'd had such a choice in
pressing matters long ago when I was
in the country that cared
less about our choices
or what kind of bag we used.
A reminder to us in America
that we sometimes don't worry
about the most important things.
If you'd read part of a poem called
The Foreigner, the second part.
>> Dunya Mikhail: Foreigner
I have that [inaudible].
The second part.
>> Ron Charles: Yes please.
>> Dunya Mikhail: You
know by the way this
in Arabic The Foreigner it was hard
to translate, it's the foreigner
and it's feminine and [inaudible]
Arabic every word is either
masculine or feminine by
there's a feminine ending.
I mean [inaudible] like for
example the room is feminine,
like the moon is masculine and
the sun is feminine and so on.
So and this was the
title like foreigner
and it's feminine ending
or has feminine ending.
But I don't know why
we couldn't do that,
I mean we didn't do it
in English that way.
But anyways.
>> Ron Charles: You would want
something like the foreign woman is
that what you're trying to
suggest a femininity about it?
Is that what you're saying?
>> Dunya Mikhail: It was [foreign
language] which is the foreigner
or stranger and his feminine ending
as if it's something attached
to it, it's a double thing.
It's the female foreigner,
is the female foreigner other
than the masculine specifically.
But the way I say it in Arabic as
if this feminine female is attached,
she's not the second, she's the
second because feminine ending.
Like I didn't say just
[foreign language]
which is we have that
[foreign language].
But I said the masculine
foreigner and his feminine ending
which means the female, but I
said it in a complicated way.
I like to make things complicated,
but sometimes I'm just like a child.
I don't know a thing about
my role in this new play
and all my lines will mean
nothing to the audience
since they understand neither
my Aramaic nor my Arabic.
So I'll imitate the gestures of
whoever I encounter on the road
as I guess their facial
expressions under the foreign sky.
I won't tremble more than a
baby leaving the test tube
against his will and I won't
cry despite all these bodies
who greet me kindly and carelessly.
I have already seen them in a dream
like me they rush to
prove they exist.
They have fingerprints
and memories and wings
and like me they sometimes gets
stricken with boredom and the flu.
They too depart for
new places though
as tourists and not the immigrants.
It's not enough after all
to complain of the climate
or of my role in this new play.
>> Ron Charles: That is you writing
about the way you feel
in this new place.
>> Dunya Mikhail: I think you're
right I have attitude but why.
>> Ron Charles: Like.
>> Dunya Mikhail: No, no you
meant a different way I know that.
>> Ron Charles: Like you're in
this new place it's like a play
and you don't entirely
know the lines,
but you have a role
you have to play.
>> Dunya Mikhail: Yes, I mean
this after all isn't this true
in the world we have a role.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Dunya Mikhail: In the world,
I mean I even have a
poem called a Second Life
where we all need a second chance
because in the beginning I thought
we Iraqis need a second life it's
not fair we lived all that way and
we're not given a second chance.
But then I wrote the
poem after I thought no,
maybe everybody needs a second life.
So it's like yes, I think
we need that second life.
>> Ron Charles: Yeah,
we all feel like we're
in a play we don't know the lines.
In one of your poems
you write outside
of Iraq I often dream
of returning home.
It's still true?
>> Dunya Mikhail: Continue
what's after,
but then I get afraid
that I get caught again.
>> Ron Charles: Yes, of course.
Do you still dream
of returning home?
>> Dunya Mikhail: You
know, it comes honestly --
two things come always
in my dream my father,
my dead father always
comes in my dream
and I always dream that I am back.
But to be honest always
not happy dream when I'm
like something happens
that I say oh,
but my daughter is not here
or something like that.
>> Ron Charles: You could go back.
>> Dunya Mikhail: I think yes,
I can now is different reasons,
but I think I can go back.
I am planning to be honest to go
back north of Iraq specifically
to visit the dead, not to
visit the living because.
>> Ron Charles Your own family?
>> Dunya Mikhail: I don't
know if I should oh my God,
a lot of terrible things,
you know, happening.
But my grandmother who was very, I
don't know maybe we don't have time
and we have a minute, two how many?
Two minutes or that we have?
And my grandmother
who was this figure
who I started my first literature
experience with her she was the one
who was telling me stories over
the roof of our house and all that.
And back in June 2014, I
watching a video of a group,
a terrorist group ISIS and they
were destroying these statutes,
these symbols.
Not only that they
were destroying graves
because there were some symbols
on them they didn't understand
like Aramaic or Hebrew writings
and or crosses or things like that.
And so that's why I thought of the
grave of my grandmother which was
in the village north in [inaudible]
that's the village we went
to when it was war.
And so I wrote a poem it was
published it's new it's not
in these books it's published
in poetry My Grandmother's
Grave, it's about that.
And so that's one reason and there
are mass graveyards now in Sinjar,
Mount Sinjar mass graveyards
of these --
most of them [inaudible] people.
And these mass graveyards
are families, are men
and there are women who were not
suitable as sex slaves and children
who refused to be separated
from them.
So I want to go and visit the
dead this time not the living,
that's what I want to do, to go.
>> Ron Charles: You
have to make that trip.
It will be a very difficult
trip on many levels.
>> Dunya Mikhail: I think, I
mean I'm serious I planned it
and everything and end
of May, beginning of June
and I have a manuscript related
so it would be good to finish this
and have myself to see
things and interview people.
So I mean I don't promise, but
I'm doing my best to do it.
>> Ron Charles: Your
daughter's name is Larisa.
>> Dunya Mikhail: Yes.
>> Ron Charles: And she's
mentioned in this poem,
this is the final lines
of the diary.
>> Dunya Mikhail: It's a great
relief to have my daughter far away
from danger, from clouds like
corpses, from kidnappers' masks,
from long lines at passport offices,
from amputated fingers in the sand.
Larisa scatters the old pictures
and mixes them with the new ones.
She mixes pictures of snowballs
in Michigan with pictures
of a round city with two
rivers, palm trees, poetry, wars,
a thousand and one nights.
Inside that city was our home.
Inside the home was our garden not
separated from the neighbors even
by a wall and inside that garden
was a raspy flower I will never
smell again.
>> Ron Charles: Thank you
so much this was lovely.
>> Dunya Mikhail: Thank you,
thank you for having me,
I really appreciate this.
Thanks.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.